Okay. So we're talking about nuclear
filling, substitution reaction.
Uh, and today we're going to talk in the
next lecture as well about mechanistic
tools,
how you find out what the mechanism is.
You can talk about a plausible mechanism,
but whether that's really it or not,
and almost always there are several,
uh, requires experimentation.
So we're going to look at tools,
uh,
experimental tools you can use to decide
what the mechanism of the reaction is.
So last time we saw a whole
bunch of examples of nuclear
affiliates substitution
reactions where a nucleophile approaches
a compound that has a low Lumo the
substrate, uh, it, uh,
reacts in a particular solvent to give
the product in which the nucleophile has
replaced the leaving group.
Okay.
So now we're interested in what
the mechanism of that is. Now,
we talked last semester
about the possibility of
attacking on the sigma star on
the carbon and the sigma star and
the leaving group leaving with, uh,
with the electrons that were formerly in
the RL bond. That's certainly plausible.
The question is whether
it's true because it's,
you'll see there are other
possibilities as well. Uh,
so there are many different mechanisms.
In fact, they're not all the same,
but they, but many of them fall in,
in the same two classes as you'll see.
And the one we're going to talk
about first is called nuclear fillic
substitution es en substitution,
nuclear fillic to means
second order and kinetics.
And you'll see what that means.
So sn two nuclear affiliate substitution.
And we're interested,
as I said in the pragmatic logic of
proving a mechanism with experiment in
theory. Now this kind of logic isn't
like the logic they teach you in,
in a philosophy or mathematics.
Things are rarely a hundred
percent proven, but there's,
but there is a practical use to know how
these things work because it can help
you in design new,
in designing new reactions or changing
the conditions to make a reaction work
better. So you'll see what it
means to prove a mechanism in,
in organic chemistry.
And actually mostly it involves
disproving all the alternative mechanisms,
right? You remember Sherlock Holmes in
the adventure of the barrel, coronet said,
it's an old maxim of mine that when
you have excluded the impossible,
whatever remains,
however improbable must be the truth.
That's generally the logic of how
you prove things and in a chemistry.
So it,
but the problem is you have to disprove
all of the alternative mechanisms,
which means you have to imagine all the
alternative mechanisms and disprove.
And of course it's always a possibility
that there's one you haven't thought of.
That's the real McCoy.
Okay?
Now let's just look at what has to happen.
You have to break the RL bond.
The leaving group has to leave
and you have to the new bonds.
So there has to be a dissociation
and there has to be an association,
and you could classify the possible
mechanisms in the sequence that's involved
in these two processes.
You could first have dissociation
and then association,
and we'll see that that actually happens.
That's called the sn one reaction.
You can have association
followed by dissociation,
which happens, but not with carbon. Okay?
And you'll see also the possibility of a
simultaneous or a concerted reaction as
you call it,
where you make the new bond at the same
time you break the old ones so that they
come at the same time. Okay? So that
seems to be pretty much the cover,
the territory of how you can do it.
Okay.
So you can have concerted where they both
happened at the same time association,
dissociation or dissociation,
followed by association.
And we can imagine reaction, coordinate
diagrams for these and geometries.
So in the concerted,
the nucleophile is coming in and
attacking the carbon at the same time the
leaving group is leaving,
and that's a transition state.
You can have a pentavalent
carbon intermediate.
So you first make the new bond and only
subsequently do you break the old bond.
Or you could break the old bond and get
a tribe Vaillant intermediate and then
subsequently make the new bond.
All right.
So if we look at the
reaction coordinate diagram,
the first one just has a transition state,
but the other two have intermediates,
right?
Either a pentavalent
intermediate of pentavalent
carbon or a try Vaillant carbon
intermediate right now
as I've drawn it there,
the first step is rate limiting.
We talked about in a complicated complex
reaction of two steps where either the
first or the second step
could be rate limiting.
It would be possible to imagine the
second step to be rate limiting as well.
However,
that might not be so common.
We will ask what's normally
the case in a reaction? Uh,
these ones where the second step is,
has a higher barrier are not so common
if you have an exothermic process because
it's against, uh, it's against
the Hammonds postulate.
Not that it couldn't be because see,
you have the intermediate
and you can go either to the,
to the product or back to
the starting material, right?
But if the second step is right liberty
and imply it implies that you have a
higher barrier going to the lower
energy product, which could be,
but it's not so likely.
So it's much more likely to have these
up at the top in a reaction that's
exothermic.
Of course the same reaction run
backwards would retrace the same path and
running this backwards would have
the second step rate limiting.
But generally we're going to talk about
cases where the first step is rate
limiting cause we're interested in
reactions that go to give a product,
not the ones that come back from the
product to the starting material so much.
Now if you have, uh,
three different others,
substituents on the carbon that's being
attacked other than the leaving group
that's leaving, then you have
the possibility of [inaudible].
Right?
So the,
the first transition state and the
pentavalent intermediate or Chiral,
but the tribe aelant intermediate,
since it's, if it's plainer,
is a chiral and that means that you're,
there are stereo chemical implications
because in the first two cases,
the nucleophile comes on on the opposite
face from where the leaving group is
leaving. But in the third case, when
you have the travail and intermediate,
it could do that, but it could
also come in from the other side.
So you would get two enantiomers.
So the stereo chemical consequences,
the stereochemistry of the product,
whether it's inverted from the
starting material or whether it's uh,
received make you tacked both sides will
tell you something about the mechanism.
I suppose if we want to be a
complete in our thinking about this,
we could also imagine that there
would be a front side attack where the
nucleophile would come in on the
same face that the, that the uh,
leaving group is leaving either in a
concerted process or in a process with the
pentavalent intermediate where nucleophile
and leaving group are on the same
side. That's a possibility
which isn't shown here,
but whichever it is,
it's [inaudible] whether it's the
same side or the opposite side,
the first two cases are going to give a
single keyer [inaudible] of the product
where the tribe and intermediate
will give both. Okay.
Now there are tools for testing that
is for excluding mechanisms and they
involve stereochemistry rate,
law rate constant and structure a
ex-ray work and quantum mechanics.
And a, in the particular book that you
might be using the, the uh, Jones book,
these are in the sections indicated. They
are now indicate those as we go along,
but these things will be
covered in all the texts, so,
so you'll see a good treatment
almost anywhere. Okay.
We're first going to look
at Stereo Chemistry, what
we were just talking about.
So when you have nuclear Felix
substitution where the nucleophile, uh,
comes in place of the leaving group,
he could either do exactly that.
It could replace the leaving group.
So the nucleophile is on the right and
the product the same way that the leaving
group was on the right
and the starting material.
So they just changed positions or
it could be a displacement where the
nucleophile comes in on the opposite side
and the things that make it chiral are
inverted. Right. You could imagine
either way. Which do you think,
if you were naive and in the 19th century,
which do you think you would think more
likely that would actually replace the
thing it took? That it was,
uh, it was exchanging with,
or that it would come in
and invert everything.
Which do you think you would
have thought was more likely?
How many would think it more likely than
if you're going to replace something,
you replace it,
how many things it would displace it.
That's exactly what they thought in
the 19th century that it should be
replacement,
not displacement.
So when it was found in 1898 that
there was an example where it,
where it inverted the configuration.
Emile Fisher,
the guy who invented the Fischer
projection after all, uh,
who was a big experience
expert on stereochemistry
at the turn of the century,
said this was the most out astounding
discovery and stereochemistry since the
groundbreaking work of Vance Hoff, which
was a quarter century earlier, right?
So he was really astounding to these
people that it could invert the
stereochemistry and they thought this
weird tastes that showed that was that
just that a weird case. But the normal
case must be replacement, right? So the,
the goal then was to find
out which one was normal.
And that's the first really
good evidence on this.
And a beautiful experiment was done in
England by Kenyon and Phillips in night
in 1923 edit involved this
alcohol and they resolved it.
And got a single Nancy
murder, which rotated light
33 degrees plus to the right.
Okay. Now they want to do
a substitution reaction,
replaced the Oah by something else.
Right?
And see whether the configuration is
the same or whether it's been inverted.
Notice incidentally, that if
you do, if in doing the process,
you do two steps,
you'll get the same ultimate product,
whether it's to inversions or
two retentions of configuration,
they'll both give the same product,
okay?
So you have to have just one step that
involves the nuclear fillic substitution
reaction. So now in the first place, Oh, H
minus, as we'll see later in the lecture,
is a crummy leaving group.
You can't undergo that,
the replacement reaction
easily with, Ooh, okay.
So what they did first was to react
it with this chloro. So phonic acid,
right? And this is indeed a nuclear
fillic substitution where, oh,
attacks sulfur this
time, not carbon, right?
And then chloride leaves.
So now you have a product where the group
attached to the chiral carbon is not,
Ooh, but oh with sulfur on it.
Right? Notice incidentally,
this, nothing happened to the
chiral carbon at this stage.
The reaction was that the oxygen,
so whatever configuration to the carbon
you had in the starting material you
have in the product, this is
not an interesting reaction
Stereo chemically, right?
It's just a way to there get there to
be a group that'll leave and notice that
this is,
this mechanism is ady.
It's first association attack the
sulfur and then dissociation lose the
chloride.
And the reason you can do that is that
there's a vacant Dior but alon sulfur.
So there's a way to that. You can form
a new bond without breaking the old one.
You don't have to attack sigma star.
And once you have this product,
that now is a good leaving group because
if you break the bond to carbon between
carbon and oxygen,
now the anti and you get as not o h minus,
but an anti analogous to the
anti in of sulfuric acid,
o s o two, right? Okay.
Now that has a rotation of plus 31 degrees
and the starting material was plus 33
degrees.
So that confirms what we were saying,
that the configuration hasn't changed
right? At the chiral carbon, am I right?
Is that a good inference
that it's plus in the product and
plus in the starting material,
does that prove that the
carbon didn't turn inside out?
How things approved it
or at least supported it?
How many think it had
nothing to do with it? Right?
Because they're different
compounds and who,
who knows how they're going
to rotate light so that
doesn't prove anything. Okay.
Now we're going to do the nuclear
Phillips substitution reaction.
Where the an eye on is acetate.
Okay,
and it's going to attack the carbon
and break the bond from carbon.
So the nucleophile attacks,
the leaving group leaves.
This is the reaction we're interested in,
whether it inverts the configuration
and we find out that we get that product
and that's the nuclear
Phillips substitution.
It's saturated carbon and the rotation
to that product is minus seven degrees.
So it was an inversion,
right?
It shows that the carbon turned inside
out because it's opposite the starting
material.
Right.
I hear you say wrong,
right?
Because it has nothing to do with it.
The same as the first step.
So we don't really know.
That proves nothing in.
The only way we're going
to prove is to get a star,
a product that's exactly the
same as the starting material,
except for the possibility
of configuration.
Then we'll know if it's the mirror image,
but we can't use any derivative. Okay?
So what we need to do is change
that. Oh, coc h three into,
Ooh, okay. And you can do that.
You can bring in hydroxide
attack at the carbon eel carbon,
which generates this
intermediate, right? And then
that can do this reaction,
breaking the CEO bond and
generate that an eye on.
Now there's another product.
Of course,
the top right of the molecule is this,
right?
You see it's got o, h, c, c h three,
and then that becomes a double bond.
So it's a CD acid, right? Incidentally,
notice this is a substitution
reaction is to the,
the reaction across the
top was a substitution.
The reaction coming down was a
substitution. The reaction going back, uh,
at the bottom is a substitution,
but the top was a substitution at sulfur.
The coming down was the one we're
interested in substitution at a saturated
carbon. The one going across is
substitution at a carbonyl carbon,
right?
That one.
So o h minus comes in and
this anti and comes off.
But again,
it's possible to do that by association
first and then dissociation,
because there's that vacant
Pi Star orbital that you
can go in without breaking
anything away.
Okay?
So we're not interested in the one on
the top and the one on the bottom or
interested in that one that comes
down the side. That's the reaction.
We're interested in nuclear physics
substitution at saturated carbon.
Okay? Now notice the,
uh, the product here.
Remember that was an acid and
this was an an ion. But of course,
this is a stronger acid than hydroxides
of the proton will be transferred in
this direction.
And now we have a product which is the
same as the starting material except
possibly for its configuration,
right?
So the question is,
is it the same as the starting material?
Is the normal course of the reaction,
a replacement or a displacement,
right?
And the rotation is minus 32 where
of plus 33 before. There's just,
that's experimental error, the
difference. So it's a displacement, right?
Inverted the configuration. And so we
know that in this kind of reaction,
backside attack on the carbon,
the kind we anticipated, uh,
although nobody could have thought about
it in 1923 on the basis of a sigma star
orbital being attacked where it's big,
okay.
So backside attack in nuclear
Phillips substitution,
that saturated carbon
and noticing this scheme,
that's the only case where you
broke a bond to that carbon.
That's the beauty and
the design of the scheme.
Now there's another nice feature
in the design of the scheme.
It looks a little clunky actually,
to have to do all those things.
And you might wonder why not avoid all
that stuff going around the bottom by
just doing hydroxide attacking
this a sulfonate Esther,
right? Cause if you brought
hydroxide in there and this left,
you'd get this product right? And you
do it without all of this stuff, right?
But there was a reason in the experimental
design they did that because if you
use hydroxide have much
stronger base than Acetate is,
then it turns out it attacks that
hydrogen and pulls it off when the leaving
group leaves. So you generate
a double bond there, right?
So you don't get the product and you,
and of course that stuff is a
chiral not you really cared. Okay.
But you don't do the reaction if you use
hydroxide. So they had to use acetate.
So this was a very clever experimental
design and proved that the,
that inversion is the normal course
backside attack on the carbon.
Okay, so inversion, right.
So the tribal and intermediate,
remember could have been attacked
from either face and would have given,
given receiving product.
So we can be confident than in this case.
That's not the mechanism.
That doesn't mean there couldn't
be a case where it's the mechanism,
but it's not the mechanism in this kind
of case and things that are related to
it.
Okay.
So Stereo chemistry is a good
tool and it shows inversion,
which means that it's not
front side attack. Right.
A concerted front side attack,
not a pentavalent intermediate where
the nucleophile came in on the same side
that the leaving group was leaving.
And it also means that you can't have
had the travail and intermediate.
Now let's look at the rate law,
what it can tell us,
how the rate depends on concentration.
So this reaction I'm showing here is f
oxide and iron attacking ethyl bromide.
So the f oxide replaces bromide,
is the leaving group and we're looking
at the rate of forming the product or
losing the starting material as a function
of how much the concentration of f
oxide is. And we're going to fix
the concentration of ethyl bromide.
It's assumed that ethyl bromide,
which is the subject of this whole thing
that rate's going to be proportional to
it. The question is, is the
rate proportional to f oxide?
So you plot the rate as a function of f
oxide and you get a line that looks like
that.
So it's a second order rate law.
It's proportional to how much ethyl
bromide you have and it's proportional to
how much f oxide you have.
So both of those things must be in
the rate determining transition state,
both the f oxide and the ethyl bromide.
Now there's something funny about this,
this plot.
Do you see what it is?
It's nice and linear.
So it's first order in f oxide,
but what else?
Asia.
It doesn't start at zero.
If you don't have any f oxide,
you get the reaction.
How can that be?
It's because although it's second order,
uh, wait a second, what just happened?
Did I press the wrong button? Oh, I,
this was just to say that the,
about the second order, sorry,
I got out of whack here.
So the initial rate limiting dissociation
in the Di dissociation to association
would give a rate independent
of nucleophile. This one,
because the first step doesn't involve
the nuclear file only the second step.
So if the rate limiting step depends
on file, it can't be this mechanism.
So we could exclude it on this basis
as well as on the Stereo Chemistry.
But, uh, back to this,
we have the problem that
I should have brought up.
How can you get the product
if there's no ethics side?
Right? So there must be a be a
reaction that's going on all the time,
whether you have a thought side or not.
And then another reaction that depends
on f oxide. What's that first reaction?
It's for, it doesn't depend on
the concentration of f oxide.
So it seems to be a first order
process. It's constant, right?
How can you get,
well first order could be
dissociation followed by association,
so there could be some of
that going on all the time.
And then a little bit of this where the
f oxide attacks getting more and more as
you have a higher concentration of
ethoughts side, but that's not what it is.
Right?
This is done in ethanol solvent,
so the unshared pair on the oxygen of
the solvent can attack the same way the
unshared pair on f oxide can.
Of course the solve the f oxide has a
much higher homo because of its negative
charge. So we'll, we'll react faster.
But there's a lot of the ethanol
there compared to how much f oxide,
especially here at the beginning when
you don't have any [inaudible] at all.
Okay.
So that actually that second process
is a pseudo first order reaction.
It depends on the concentration
of ethanol, but ethanol,
solvent's concentration
is constant, right? So it,
it appears to be first order,
it's,
but it's actually some pseudo first order
a process where the first order rate
constant is k pseudo times
the concentration of ethanol,
which is not changing.
Okay,
so now we have these
two possible reactions.
F oxide or ethanol unshared pair
attacking the sigma star of Ethyl Bromide.
Right?
Now we can tell by how much
of this at this point here,
say when it's half and half, half the
mechanism is the pseudo first order,
half the rate is the second order.
Then we know that that whatever the
difference in these rate constant is,
is made up by the difference
in concentration so that
they have the same rate.
Okay? That is there's enough f
oxide, a small amount of f oxide,
but with a much higher rate constant.
So it has the same overall rate as the
pseudo first order rate constant does.
And from that you can figure out that
the second order rate constant is 20,000
times faster than the
first order rate constant.
So this is 20,000 times faster than
that now. Does that make sense to you?
Yeah, it does. Because you'd expect the,
the much higher homo of of the
and I n to attack more rapidly.
How much more rapidly do you have any
way of measuring how reactive these two
things should be?
These two homos,
any way of measuring how high the
relative height of those two homos
and their ability to form a bond.
It's what we talked about
in the last lecture.
[inaudible] PKA.
How different are they in
attacking approach? Okay,
so the analogy to that is attacking
protons and that's an equilibrium that's
easy to measure by the
way we did last time.
And we find out that their pks differ by,
uh,
by what,
17 and a half powers of 10 right here
or are they differ by only a little more
than four powers of 10 so you
might expect it to be even bigger,
right? The difference. Right. But in fact,
this has measured at equilibrium when
you've completely formed the bond.
Whereas in the nuclear
Phillips substitution, we're
only at a transition state.
We haven't completely formed a bond,
right?
So you don't expect it to be as as big
a difference by the Hammond postulate
kind of thing. You're only a part of the
way across. Not all the way. So it's not,
maybe not surprising that this is,
this seems a plausible rate rate
ratio in that rate constant ratio.
Okay,
so that makes sense.
So the rate law then shows that it
can't be dissociation first because that
wouldn't depend on how much
a nucleophile you have there,
nor can it be front side attack,
either concerted or
pentavalent intermediate and
then lose the leaving group.
It has to be from the uh,
from the backside. Okay.
Now another thing you can test is not
just how it depends on concentration,
but what the rate constant is.
In fact,
we just looked in the last
slide at whether these rate
constants were plausible
for a higher homo and a lower homo,
right?
So the rate constant will depend certainly
on what the nucleophile is hydro f
oxide versus ethanol, but will
also depend on what are, is,
what the leaving group is,
what the solvent is, right?
It also may be on the nature
of the product, for example,
whether the product is charged or not.
Right?
So all of these things will do,
will influence the rate constant.
And we're going to look at at the whole
set of them one of the time and see
whether these, tell us something about
the mechanism of the reaction. First,
let's look at the
substrate. The, our group.
So here are different
ours and the relative rate
constant for how fast they get
attacked by iodide,
uh,
uh, in, in acetone,
solvent at room temperature when
bromide is the leaving group.
So this is how,
how the relative rates as we change our,
we'll call Ethel one.
Okay.
Then methyl is much faster.
But propyl is about the same rate.
Okay.
I saw propyl is ever so much slower.
Yeah.
The, the ISO butyl is faster. Again,
t butyl is very slow.
In fact,
you don't know how slow it is.
It's gotta be slower than that because
something else happens other than the
reaction we're talking about.
So all you know is that it can't
be any faster than that, right?
And neopentyl is really,
really slow.
Hey, now do these make sense? Uh,
let's look at it in two ways.
First,
we can have the substituents
on the Alpha carbon,
the carbon that has the levy group
on it. And notice here we add, uh,
one methyl group to that carbon.
Here we've added two methyl
groups to that carbon.
Here we've added three
methyl groups to that carbon.
So we can have alpha substitution,
but we can also have Beta substitution.
We can add methyls to this carbon.
Here we put one methyl on that carbon
here we've put two methyls on that second
carbon here, we've put three
methyls on that second carbon.
So we can try to classify it as we put
extra methyls on a particular carbon.
So those are the Beta substituents.
For example, one, two,
or three methyl groups on
that Beta carbon. Okay?
Now notice that is we put a
methyl group on the Alpha carbon,
right?
The first carbon,
we add a methyl group to it in place of
hydrogen that increases their d that,
uh, as we add, it decreases
the rate by 145 times.
So there's a higher activation energy,
enough to slow it by 145 fold.
Okay,
now let's put a second one
on that slows it down by 128.
Another factor of 128 about the same.
So the influence of the first methyl
group is about, as in slowing it down,
it's about the same as the influence
of the method. The second methyl group.
How about the third methyl group?
Do you see what it does?
Oh,
incident.
So that means that it's raising the
activation energy by about the same amount
each time you do that.
So you might think that the third
one would do it by that amount. Uh,
but in fact it's,
it's all you know,
is that it's that it's greater than
15 times. Can't really measure it,
right? Because something
else happens. Okay.
Now let's look at the same thing
with respect to the Beta hydrogen.
The first one slows it down.
Almost not at all. What?
From one to 0.82 only by a factor
of 1.2 the second one flows.
It slows it down by a factor of
23 but how about the third one
slows it by 3000 fold.
Why does the third one makes so much
difference where the first two don't make
much difference of adding those
methyl groups? Okay, well here's the,
here's the case in methyl with bromide
ready to leave and we have to attack the
backside, or let us suppose
we're attacking the backside,
which seems plausible on the basis of the
stereochemistry and the rate constant.
Okay, that means we're
attacking that Lumo. Okay,
now let's look at that same thing. In the
case of the, of the Alpha substitution,
there's that between the red and the
and the second blue as the anti-bonding
node that's going to break. Okay,
here's the surface potential,
right? And that's the blue area is
the good place to put an an eye on,
so that makes sense now,
so we have methyl ethyl,
I saw propyl and t butyl,
right?
Let's look at the total
electron densities. Notice
methyl, the Arrow gets there.
Okay, Ethel, it gets there. Okay.
Although it's bumping into this
thing at the back a little bit,
but it could lean forward for
just a little bit to avoid that.
Here it's getting in trouble,
right?
That slows it down by
a factor of 23 right?
But let's say I've got the wrong one.
This was a hundred that's another hunt
factor of a hundred but this one is a
much bigger factor because,
because you just can't get there.
Now when you have three,
so the third one is what really stops it,
and this is called steric hindrance.
The space gets in the way, right?
So that's the effect of Alpha methylation.
Let's look at the Lumo.
It looks pretty complicated,
but let's,
but the reason I've put it
up is not to look at that,
but to look at that one orbital in the
context of the total electron density.
So there it is at 0.06 contour,
and now I'll put the total electron
density there and look through that to see
how much we can see of that. Lumo
that we need to attack. So you see,
you can really see it here.
You can see it a little bit
here and a little bit here,
but you can't see it at all
from the backside here, right?
So this one is going to be shut down,
okay?
And there's the surface potential and
you see the surface potentially even the
surface potential isn't as good here as
it is in the other ones for the anti and
to come in and attack.
Now let's look at the Beta methylate
methylation where we have this car,
but then we start putting one,
a t one two or three on that one,
right?
And here are the rates mirror 1.8 2.036
and then 0.012 why is the third one so
bad? Right? Well,
you'll see this one can get in there.
That one can get in there just as well,
because this methyl group,
the substituent is out of the way.
You can put two of them out of the way.
But the third one you can't get out
of the way. Once you have three,
there is no way to avoid it.
So that one gets slowed way down.
No way to avoid the third Beta methyl
group. And there you can see the,
that you can't get any place near
the really good blue areas. Okay.
So, uh, uh,
this is consistent with the idea that
you have transitioned state involves
backside attack, right? Not
The planar intermediate. Okay.
Now there's a question,
might it be possible to
have front side attack?
Might it be just easier to do backside
but you could do front side attack if you
want. If, if, if the
other one weren't faster,
how hard is it to do front side
attack? Right? Okay. So is this,
is this possible?
Okay.
Or is it possible to form a cat,
Diane,
that's not planer,
right?
So could you have it bent and not
planer so that the stereo chemical
consequences would not
necessarily be inversion? Right?
Might it be possible to have a non
planar cat ion as an intermediate?
But remember that that Bh three,
which has the same electrons
that that c h three plus does,
remember we talked last semester about
x h three. That one that's a cat Diane,
or be in VH three.
You expect it to be plainer but still
might it be not too bad to have it bent.
Okay,
so this was the subject of one of the uh,
second really classic
experiment in the 20th century.
The first one I talked about,
which I really love,
is that Kenyon and Phillips that
proves that it must be inversion,
but there's another one that shows that
it's not possible to have front side
attack. At least it's, it's, it's very,
very hard and it's not possible
to have a non planar cat I,
and at least it's very, very hard.
And that was in this experiment,
this paper published in 1939,
which if you click there,
you can download a copy of the paper
by Bartlett and Knox. So this is the,
your grant, your chemical
grandfather, right? PD Bartlett,
who was a young man at that time.
He was a 32 years old and Knox who was
his graduate student who was almost the
same age because he was
an African American.
There was one of the first African
Americans to get a phd in, uh, in,
in Chemistry and was uh,
and uh,
if you click on that asterisk
you can download a story, uh,
an account of his life,
which is fascinating.
He's the grandson of a slave and
he had a lot of trouble in, in his,
that's why he was old at the time.
He got his phd.
But you can read about it there
if you want to. At any rate,
they specifically designed and prepare
this molecule to test the mechanistic
questions. This is, this is rather
different than just taking things,
reacting to messing around,
observing what happens and
then trying to interpret it.
They specifically designed a molecule
that would test these questions about
whether you could have front side attack,
whether you could have a non planar
cad ion and the one that wouldn't be
complicated by other problems.
So they thought through very carefully
and design it and then Knox had to
prepare it and study it. Right. Okay.
Now this is a comment about that paper.
In 1939,
Bartlett and knocks published the
account of their work on the bridge,
head chloride, apoe camp, full
chloride. That's where x equals c l.
I believed then and I believe now that
this was a fantastically influential
paper for 30 years afterwards.
No one really accepted any mechanism
unless it had been tested out on a bridge
head case.
Indeed,
the Bartlett knocks paper shaped the
interests and viewpoint of many chemists
about the kind of physical
organic they wanted to do.
And that's a quote from John D.
Roberts,
who's an institute
professor at Cal Tech and,
and one of the real leaders of organic
chemistry through the 20th century and
he's still living now. He
said that in 1975. Okay.
So this is a, this is a structure of
that molecule in balls and sticks.
And, uh, it became so important,
this kind of structure that people who
are in the field know how to draw quickly.
And I'll show you how to draw it,
okay?
It has that stick structure and
here's how you draw you first forum.
Or I do any how different
people draw different ways,
but you draw this sort of a distorted w,
right?
And then you start at the nearest carbon
and draw up and down and to the right.
And then you draw the last bond and you
draw it last because it goes behind that
one. So you make it broken. So it has
a sort of a three d aspect to it. Okay?
So that's, that's this, uh, this
case. And notice what it is,
is a boat Cyclo Hexane,
right?
That has a bridge across the top.
So it's a bridged compound.
And formally it's called a bicycle.
Oh. Heptane. It's got seven carbons,
the six of the cyclohexane
plus the bridge, right?
And you give numbers in brackets in
the middle of bicycle to say how many
carbons there are in each bridge.
So there's a two carbon
bridge between these two,
a two carbon bridge and a
one carbon bridge. Okay.
And that those two positions
are called bridge heads, right?
So this is a bridge head chloride
that we have in the molecule,
the apple cam full
chloride that they studied,
that they designed and then
prepared to study, okay,
now here's a space filling model of
it and there's where you would have to
attack to get at the
backside of Sigma Star.
So that's obviously out of the
question that you could get in there.
So the molecule is designed so you
can't do backside displacement.
The question is if you can't do backside,
can you do front side displacement,
right?
So the attack would have to be front side.
Now notice something else
about this structure, right?
That if you were to flatten that carbon,
if you were to lose the chloride without
attacking it and generate the cad I and,
and generate a flat cat ion,
that would require generating really
strongly strained angles here or here and
here. Right. And it was
estimated by Bartlett,
the knocks that that would cost
more than 23 kilocalories per mole,
which three fourths of that is 16 right?
So it would be 10 to the minus
16 factor in rate. Right?
Forget that.
Okay,
so they've designed the molecule so it
can't go backside displacement and it
can't give the cat die and either lose
the chloride degenerate the cat. Right?
So the cat eye,
and if you were to get a cat ion,
it would have to not be plainer,
otherwise it would be slowed down
by 10 to the 16th fold. Okay.
So they've set up to answer
those two questions now. Now,
but there's another possible competition.
Remember in the Kenyan and Phillips,
they couldn't use hydroxide.
They had to use acetate
because the reaction would
go otherwise if they used the
strong base hydroxide.
So Mike,
Competition from loss of Hcl to generate
a double bond be a problem here.
Well, although there are hydrogens
on the carbon adjacent to the cl,
the carbon bearing, the chloride,
there are Beta hydrogens,
but they're not in the position you
would need in order to get elimination.
Notice that if you had
hydrogens here, here, and here,
then you could do the elimination,
right? This is anti to the leaving group.
So you could do that and
make a double bond there,
but there are not hydrogens
here or here or here,
right?
So you can't do the elimination.
Those are Gauche not anti to the chloride.
That's going to be leaving, right?
So,
and even if you could break off h and cl,
this would be the double
bond you would generate.
Now think about that double bond,
right?
Here's The p orbital on the carbon
that used to have the chlorine in it,
right?
But here's The p orbital on the
carbon that now has only one hydrogen.
What's wrong?
They don't overlap,
right? There's horrid overlap. So in fact,
there's a rule called Brett's rule that
the carbon carbon double bond cannot
originate from such a bridge
head. Incidentally, I just,
I looked up Brett's paper yesterday
and it's interesting that Brett himself
calls it Brett's rule.
Usually somebody else names
that in honor of the inventor.
But Brett didn't wait around.
Okay,
so would competitions from loss
of hcl make it hard to do? No.
So here's the beauty of the
design of this molecule.
It can't do backside displacement.
If it forms a cad I and it has to be
a non planar cat ion and it can't do
elimination. So how reactive visit, well,
here's the part of the
paper that discusses that.
It says all attempts to
replace the chlorine failed.
You can't do displacement on this bridge.
Head chloride,
they refluxed it for 21 hours with 30%
potassium hydroxide at 80% ethanol.
And they didn't get any reaction.
Notice they said they were,
it was a little hard to do because the,
these vigorous conditions
attack the glass,
but they didn't attack
this molecule. Okay? Okay.
So that front side attack where
you can't come at the backside,
you'd have to come in from the front,
must be at least a million times slower
than the typical backside attacks and
probably much, much
slower than that. Okay.
Now how about the possibility of forming
the cad and they said they refluxed it
with silver nitrate in aqueous
ethanol solution for two days. Right?
What's the idea of the silver?
Because silver can attack the unshared
pair on chlorine and form of bond and
break the bond to,
to uh,
from the ar to leave a cat
die and have our right.
So instead of pushing by
attacking the backside,
you pull the chloride off, pulled the
chloride off, leaving the cad ion.
So that's a good way to
generate a cad ions, right?
Except in this case,
it didn't work.
There was no opalescence that
is the solution remained clear.
Why opalescence?
Because if you get this reaction,
the sodium chloride makes a precipitate.
And if you get just a little bit of it,
you can see a little bit of cloudiness
there, but they saw none. In fact,
as you can read here,
the reaction of silver nitrate with,
with one claw apple campaign is at least
two times 10 to the minus 10th at about
85 degrees. Now, the reaction in, in, uh,
in this one, uh, which,
uh, partly this compound,
so it's carbon that has two
methyls at an ethyl on it. Uh,
that one is this,
this one here is at least a
billion times slower than that.
And when this one was measured,
it was done 60 degrees cooler and
without the silver pulling on it.
So it's many, many, many
powers of 10 difficult to form,
more difficult to form this
cat eye and one that's bent.
So you can't form or at least it's very
hard to form bent cat ions and it's very
hard to do front side attack.
So this was a beautiful experiment that,
that showed that where they specifically
designed a molecule to answer these
questions and,
and,
and it succeeded than it became the model
for many kinds of mechanistic studies
that were done over the
next 30 years. Now. Uh,
they're also an interesting cases
when the r group is in a ring.
So here's a no ring at all, just two
methyl groups than a three, four,
five and six membered rings and
we're going to displace the bromide.
Now cyclo pental bromide is almost
exactly the same rate as ice appropriate
bromide, which we're taking to
be one for relative purposes,
but Cyclo butyl is, is,
is very much slower.
What does that 200 times slower,
right?
And cyclo propyl is very,
very much slower than that.
Now, any ideas about why? Why?
There's nothing problem with cyclopentane,
but Cyclo butyl and Cyclo are bad.
What do you think about when
you compare those rings,
Chris Straight, right, exactly.
That one has 109 degree bond
angle and so does cyclopentane,
but the others have very small
bond angles. Now wait a second.
This strain is in the starting material.
If you destabilize the starting material,
you should make a reaction faster,
not slower.
So that in itself seems to be backwards,
right?
What the heck is going on?
Well,
let's think about the transition
state for the reaction.
How hard does it get from the starting
material to the transition state?
That's what determines the rate.
So the transition state
looks like this and it wants,
it's sp squared hybridized to make those
bonds to the original substituents.
So it wants to have 120 degree bond
angle beforehand at wanted to have 109
degree bond angle. Now it wants
the bond angle to be even bigger.
So if you have a 60 degree bond angle
and it wants to be 120 that's worse than
having 60 when it wants to be a 109 so
indeed the starting material is strained,
right? But the transition
state is even more strained.
So you always have to compare the starting
material on the transition state in a
situation like this.
So the increased strain in the
transition state is what slows it down.
Now how about cyclohexane?
It has a 109 degree bond angle here,
right? But it's slowed down, right?
It can't be this kind of fake.
It could go to 120 no problem.
No problem with making 120
Bhanda degree bond angle here.
Can you see what the problem
is in the six membered ring?
Why is it slower than five?
You remember the shape of the five
membered ring? It's almost flat.
A little bit puckered, right?
But cyclohexane is the chair,
right?
Which means that that chloride is running
into these two ch two groups right
here in cyclopentane.
Those other groups would be out here,
not up here,
right?
And you notice that it's strained
because that's the, the, the,
the line between the leaving group,
the nucleophile is bent here.
This thing is being pushed
back, right? So that's the,
so there's a different kind of strain
in this case that slows it down by a
factor of 200 compared to that one.
Okay?
So we've seen the rate constant
dependence on the nucleophile, right?
Let's now, now we're, we've,
we've looked at it on our,
now we're going to look at it just
really quickly on the nuclear file. Okay?
So here are a bunch of nuclear files and
they get faster and faster and faster.
Okay? Now, is it the same with
a proton? How about the pks?
Well here,
uh,
if we look at this water
as a leaving group,
fluoride and hydroxide,
you'll see that indeed as it gets to be,
uh, uh, wait a second,
as it gets to be a stronger acid.
Yeah,
it's slow.
Is that right?
A weak acid is fast.
Does that reasonable or is that backwards?
A weak acid means it holds
onto a proton tightly.
Right?
But it also, we see is holding onto
a carb attacking a carbon. Well,
so that makes sense, right?
That makes a lot of sense. Okay,
so for first row elements,
the nuclear physics Felicity attack on
Sigma Star parallels basis of the attack
on h plus both require a high higher
home. We'll, we'll make it more reactive.
So far so good.
Now let's look at the halides
fluoride chloride bromide iodide.
Notice that is the,
as the acid gets stronger,
it speeds up.
Now it's backwards.
The halides are going backwards.
The better they are at attacking a proton,
the worst they are at attacking carbon.
That doesn't make sense.
And we see actually the same
thing here for oxygen and sulfur.
Sulfur is a,
is a stronger acid,
but it's better at attacking carbon.
This seems nuts.
Okay?
Now this is actually tied in to the effect
of solvent because if you look at the
relative rates in,
in water for attacking methylene iodide
with these different nuclear files,
you see this, which is essentially
what we see here. This is,
this is 14 times faster.
Here's 10,000 this is 160 times faster.
Here it's 80 times faster.
These are generic numbers and these are
specific ones for a particular case,
okay? But look what happens
if you do it in acetone,
it turns around.
So it's what you expect and acetone,
but it's backwards in water.
What's special about water?
Why are things backwards in water?
What's different about water and acetone?
Water forms.
Hydrogen bonds.
And when you form a hydrogen
bond to an an eye on, right,
you deactivate it.
You have to break the hydrogen bond in
order for it to attack something else,
right? So you can see that
this is sensible and acetone,
but as backwards and water,
because it's harder to break hydrogen
bonds to the smaller ions, right?
So as the ions get big like I have died,
then they're not very
much hydrogen bonded.
And even though they're not so good
at attacking protons there, in fact,
veteran attacking carbons, cause you
don't have to break the water away. Okay.
We'll continue with this stuff next time.
Thanks.